okay
cool you were working under the
assumption this would be a good thing to
get to
which it is
how do i use it
when you rotate this
what does the annulus look like
there you go there it is right
now careful careful
what would you call that height
there
what would be an appropriate
name for it
i would call it delta h
it's not in terms of it's not a change
in x it's not a changing y you're going
up this way because that's how i sliced
it right
so therefore a good name for that would
be delta h cool good
now
what's the radius
well you know what i didn't care all
that much because i want the radius
squared anyway
right like when i'm working out this
it'll be pi
radius squared
times delta h here go okay
ah hold on i'm really close really close
think about this
volume equals okay what are the pieces
that go into this i'm going to take the
limit as all of those slices approach
zero
okay
what am i going to add up
i'm going to add up a whole bunch of
these guys
right
pi times
r squared
right
times the little height that little
little height
what's missing
i need boundaries i need boundaries okay
now it's a bit weird because we're used
to batteries just being nice x values or
y values but now
i'm after an h
value but that's okay that's all right
look at this guy he's super well defined
okay where does
this um
volume right where does it go from
it looks like goes from here
all the way up
to there
right
can we work out what those values are
yeah i think we can right how do we work
this out why not this one's an easy one
what do i have to solve well this is
just y equals x
right okay
and uh sorry uh this right xy equals 1.
so that's 1 1.
but that's an x value
and that's a y value
and i want an h value
right where does h go h is here
that's a one one root two triangle isn't
it right
square root there you go so there's my
starting point
see that
right different axes different axes okay
how far do i go i started to i have to
go all the way up to here
so how do i solve that what's that
that's just this line
and this line
so i'm going x equals 4 minus x
2x equals 4 x is a half
right
but
did i do so wrong sorry 2. but that's
that's not an h value either right
so how do i use that
it's just it's just it's similarity
isn't it i've got similar triangles
going here it's the same triangle
that one one root two triangle except
it's twice as big so it'll be two two
two or two somewhere
okay how's your brain
doing okay
in a melted mess on the floor now you're
doing well
all right we fit all together
there's my
sum of all these things okay how am i
going to write the integral
pi out the front okay
root 2 to 2 root 2
and then this is what i'm integrating ah
is that all
okay now we've transitioned from talking
about the sum of a whole bunch of
annulus shaped things right which have
taken care of all of the um
um rotation for us right
and then this guy well just out of
interest right
you remember when i said i said
right uh if you were doing this
right
or all your variables would be different
wouldn't they
okay so for instance
which which one would we go we'll go
around this way wouldn't we
you could say that couldn't you
surely you could because it's a dummy
variable it doesn't matter right anyway
i'll put it back to h's because that's
what we worked out
okay
pi out the front what's the integral
what's the primitive
h cubed one three
2h
yep
you can do this can't you should we just
do it
okay of course what's that
that's the um
eight
times two two sixteen root two
minus
two
minus
okay what do we get
two root two one three
minus two
two
is that all right
do my numbers check out yes
sixteen root two minus two two
that's fourteen root two on three minus
four two plus two two
minus two two
which is really
6 root 2 on 3
so you're getting pi
times 8 root 2
on 3
units cubed
not bad for a wedo looking rotator thing
i'm curious if any of you want to try to
think about that approach we thought of
before thinking about the equivalent
hyperbola which is
round the right way at 45 degrees and
then you can work out all the same
pieces
just curious we should get the same
volume out i guess i wonder how
different the numbers would be
i wonder if we would end up at exactly
the same integral it's possible
anyway
okay so um
that was a lot of work i admit um these
volumes come up quite seldom okay but i
want you to know in some ways okay hold
on what was different between this
question and the one we did at the start
of the lesson what was different
okay process wise
what's different what did we do
differently
yeah we had to do a bit of quarter
geometry didn't we um
we had to think harder about this and
the triangles that were there so that we
could work out because height and radius
don't just fall out at you right but
then once you've got those it's a volume
just like any other so you can compute
it just like any other which i think is
brilliant